[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS LATIMER: My
name is Chris Latimer.
I'm one of the product managers
that works on APIs and API
management for Google.
So I'm part of the team that
runs the Apigee Platform.
And I've been working on
APIs for a really long time.
In fact, when I first
started off looking at APIs,
it was in the context of
service-oriented architecture.
And we were always having
conversations about things
like, should we use SOAP?
Should we use REST?
Which one is better
for enterprises?
And at the time,
the feeling was SOAP
was this enterprise
technology, and REST
was more something for
the Facebooks and Twitters
of the world, this kind
of novel technology
that really wasn't
enterprise-ready.
And so it's interesting to see
the changes that have happened
over the last 10 or so years.
Because now APIs are everywhere.
You can't really go more
than 5 or 10 minutes
over the course of a day
without using some type of API.
Any time you pick
up your phone, it's
probably making an API call.
So if you check your social
media today, API calls.
If you are checking in for
your flight to go home,
if you're not a local,
that's probably an API call.
If you do things like purchase
something online, again,
another API call.
And so it should come as
absolutely no surprise
that, with all of these
critical things that
are running on APIs
for our organizations,
APIs need security.
And normally, the type of
picture that we think of
is something like this.
So we don't want to
have our organization be
on the front page of
Google News saying,
yet another data
breach has happened.
And now we're responsible
for taking this information
that our customers
have trusted us with
and accidentally leaked it out
so that hackers now have access
to our passwords and
our personal information
and those type of things.
And the natural inclination
that we typically have
is to do something like this--
to lock up all of our data.
How can we take our
data and our APIs
and make them as secure
as possible so absolutely
nobody can get access to them?
But the problem is, if that's
our approach to API security
and, all of a sudden, we've
lock things down so much
that we can't actually
use them, we're
going to miss out on
all the value of APIs.
And so when we're trying
to actually build out
API security, locking things
down isn't the hard part.
It would be easy enough for
us just to not build an API.
And that's the most
secure API of all.
But trying to foster
innovation, allowing
the people who can build
really interesting things
with our APIs,
and not putting in
place really
heavy-weight bottlenecks
and unnecessary delays while
keeping our APIs secure
is a much, much harder
problem for us to solve.
And that's what we're going
to talk about here today
in this session.
So the way that we put
this talk together is I
went and I spent a lot
of time-- so in my role,
I spend a lot of
time with customers.
And I get a chance to
talk with organizations
from all around the country,
all around the world.
And I like to ask them
what sort of things
they're concerned about.
And so what we did
is we started off
by looking at specific
customer examples
and how those customers are
addressing their security
needs.
So we'll start off with
a pretty basic one.
So we have a lot
of retail customers
that we work with at Apigee.
And a lot of times, they'll
have APIs like this.
These are things like
store locations and hours.
So we're not looking at
sensitive information.
I mean, we want people to
know when our stores are open.
We want people to be able to
find our store location so they
can come to the
stores when they're
open to do purchasing with us.
But at the same time, it's
important information.
So we probably have
these type of APIs
attached to our mobile app.
We do want to make sure that
this API does remain secure
so that people can
actually use it.
So what type of
things do we have
to be concerned about with
an API that's like this--
no sensitive information but,
yet, relatively important?
Well, I know that
in a security talk--
I've done a number of security
talks over the years--
and one of the things
that I've noticed
is that, if I don't mention
TLS as the very first thing,
and I've got some security
people in the audience,
you get very nervous that
I didn't mention TLS.
So I'm going to go
ahead and get out
of the way at the beginning.
There are some basic
things that we want to do.
At this point, TLS is
just sort of implied
that we're always going to
put TLS on top of our APIs.
So now that that's out of
the way, the other things we
have to think about--
one of the one customer that
I talked with, he put it best.
He said, "Every time I
onboard a new application,
I've just onboard a
new potential source
of a DDoS attack."
And that doesn't
necessarily mean that people
are intentionally DDoS-ing.
But somebody could do
something incorrectly.
They could build an app
that, all of a sudden,
just has more traffic than
they were anticipating.
And all of a sudden,
before you know it,
you have floods of traffic
that are coming into this API,
and they end up
inadvertently taking it down.
And again, with something
like a store locator,
that means that, if somebody
is on your mobile app,
and they're trying to
get access to your store
or find the closest store,
suddenly that customer
can no longer actually
come into the store.
So we have to think about
things like, even with this
API that we want people
to have access to,
we want them to
be able to use it,
how can we allow them to use it
in a way that doesn't introduce
unnecessary risk?
So traditionally, our approach
to this type of problem
was to enforce some type
of heavyweight governance.
So before I joined
Apigee, and before we
were acquired by
Google, I spent a lot
of time working for a
large insurance company.
In our approach, whenever
we wanted to share data,
it was very much a matter
of picking up the phone
or sending an email and saying,
hey, I know you have a service.
I'd like to use this
in my application.
And usually, the response
was something like, great,
let's sit down.
When can we get together,
and you can fill out
this 100-question questionnaire
about everything you're
going to do with my data.
And then we'll understand
your business justification.
And then we'll decide if
we're going to give you access
or not.
And over the course of weeks of
getting together and reviewing
and security
reviews, ultimately,
you would get access to the API.
And for no very good
reason, we ended up
delaying our ability to actually
get something out the door.
So a much better
approach this is just
to enforce traffic management.
There's nothing sensitive
about this information.
It's just store
locations and hours.
So what if we could give
access to anyone who wanted it,
either within our
organization or outside,
depending on the API
you're working with,
and say, you can have
access to it automatically.
We'll give you
access to this API.
However, we're going
to limit that access.
So if you wanted to make more
than, say, 100 calls an hour
or 1,000 calls an hour,
whatever is appropriate,
we're just going to start
throttling that traffic,
and we're not going
to give you access.
So we don't have to worry
about the flood of traffic
coming in and inadvertently
doing a denial of service.
And we can also open up this
API so more people can use it.
The other traditional
approach that we would see
is something like
a service registry.
And in this sense, I'm not
talking about the service
registries that have
come along recently
in a microservices-based
architecture.
I'm talking about the old-school
web service repositories
and registries and
those type of things
where we would try
to keep track of, OK,
who has access to this API.
And we'll note down who might be
the potential source of floods
of traffic that are coming in.
A much better approach
is to automate that.
So with platforms like the API
management platforms, usually,
we can do things
like issue API keys.
And so if we wanted to
be able to look and see
exactly who's making which calls
and how much traffic coming in,
API keys provide us a
great way of doing that.
Now, we have an
identifier we can
use to track our traffic
that's coming through
and to enforce those quotas.
So we know that, as an API
call comes in, it has a key,
this is the app, this is
what the apps entitled to.
And we'll start throttling
those things right away.
The other thing we
have to be aware of
are content-based attacks.
So even though this particular
API doesn't intentionally
expose sensitive data, somebody
may try to get around that.
They may try to send in requests
that the API is not expecting.
Maybe they're doing things
like SQL injection attacks
or cross-site scripting.
And so we want to
be able to protect
against those
miscreants that are
trying to send in negative
attacks into our API.
So this is usually
where we start
to think about the
capabilities of an API gateway
and how we can use an
API gateway to intercept
those calls and to actually
enforce rules that will protect
against content-based attacks.
And even though I
don't want to make
this a commercial about
Apigee, it just so
happens that Google
has a platform called
Apigee that solves all of
these security problems.
And again, if you want to talk
about Apigee, if you have more
questions about your APIs and
API security, I'm happy to dive
into those details.
And again, these are
all customer examples
that we've talked to
and worked with as we
put this talk together.
So the next API that we
talked with-- so this
is actually an
insurance company.
And one of the
challenges with insurance
is that it's a
highly-regulated business.
And so in this
particular example,
what we had is this
insurance company,
they have a product that
they work with a partner.
So if you're a Delta Airlines
or a Southwest Airlines,
and you want to offer
travel insurance,
you can't just offer
your own product.
There are regulations about who
can sell insurance in any given
state.
And so this insurance company
that we were working with
offered a travel
insurance product
that these partners could use.
And so we were talking with
them about the security concerns
that they had.
So one of the first things
that they were worried about
is compliance with
industry regulations.
So they basically
said, when we're
working with a Delta Airlines
or some really large company,
they can, of course,
dedicate the six months
required to go through all
of these formal approval
processes.
We can put in place
the controls we
need to make sure that
we're complying with all
the insurance regulations.
But when we look at the
travel industry as a whole,
there's a whole niche market.
So do we have anybody
here from India?
Seriously?
Nobody at all?
Oh, OK.
OK, so I work with I work with
a lot of people from India.
And I've noticed that there are
special dedicated travel sites
that are just for
trips to India,
finding cheap trips to
India, the best times to go,
and they offer ways
to buy this insurance.
But these are very
small travel sites.
They're not on par
with a Travelocity
or an Orbitz or
a Delta Airlines.
And these smaller
companies, they
can't invest the same
amount of time and effort.
And there are too many of them
out there for the insurance
company to actually go and
invest that time as well.
So they said, we'd like to
reach these smaller companies,
but we're in a quandary
here around exactly how
we're going to do that.
We have to comply
with regulations.
So how can we help?
So the traditional approach
was we just wouldn't.
We would just work
with the companies who
could afford to spend
the time with us
to put together a tiger team
that's going to go through.
And six months later of
meetings, and compliance,
and auditors, we'll feel
confident that they can sell
our products, and others can't.
So what they found
was they could
productize APIs in
such a way that they
can offer them in a self-service
way to these smaller companies.
So whereas a large company,
in order to do things
like actually sell
an insurance product,
you didn't have the
same regulations just
to get a quote on an
insurance product.
So they said, what if we
could take our partner API
and we could productize that
in such a way that we offer,
in a self-service
automated fashion,
anybody can come
and offer a quote.
And we'll do a revenue
share model with them
so that we can comply
with regulations.
We'll be the ones that
are actually selling
the product, not the partner.
But we can offer them a way to
still comply with regulations.
And in doing so, what
they ended up doing was
they would enforce
fine-grained access control.
So depending on
who you are and who
you were that was coming
into their API program,
they could say, we're only going
to let you see and get access
to these very specific
pieces of our API.
So we can still foster the
innovation that we're after.
But we're only going to give the
full ability to actually sell
an insurance product
to our big partners
who are willing to go
through this process with us.
And when it came to
actually enforcing
this at the runtime
perspective, what they'd do
is they say, well, great,
when somebody signs up,
we're going to give
you credentials.
And you'll use those credentials
to obtain an OAuth token.
So when an OAuth token comes
in, we're going to look,
and we're going to say, which
products do you have access to?
Do you have access
to the ability
to sell the insurance
product or just
to get a quote on the
insurance product?
And so in this way,
they were going
to take an existing API
that they had built it out
for their partners.
And they were able to
repurpose it in such a way
that they can now support a
tremendously larger number
of partners.
Now, one of the last ones
that we'll talk about here--
so I was working with
a large hospital chain.
And so they probably have one
of the more interesting APIs
that I've come across.
So what they've done is they
have wired up their ICU.
So they have very, very sick
patients that are coming in.
They've got a lot of
sensors and information
that's constantly flowing
back from the ICU.
They've got all the
patients' medical data.
And they're taking that,
and they're building out
of a risk assessment.
So every day, if you're a
physician at this hospital
and you have a patient in the
ICU, it's going to tell you,
here are the patients that are
in the most critical state.
And here are the
things that we've
seen that have led to either
death or negative outcomes
that we should be aware of,
and here is a treatment plan.
And so you can imagine,
in this particular case,
you're dealing with
HIPAA-compliant data.
You're dealing with very
sensitive PII data, of course,
that's coming through.
And as a result, they had some
really major security concerns.
So what should this
particular organization
be concerned about?
Well, this was, by far and
away, their biggest concern.
When you're dealing
with HIPAA, there
are real, legal,
criminal consequences
that you can run into
if all of a sudden you
take a patient's
information-- in fact, one
of the hospitals
that they run, they
ended up having some
celebrities coming in.
And all of a sudden,
you had people
that wanted to take a sneak
peek at their medical records
and ended up finding some
people, actually, in here.
So they wanted to make
sure nobody ended up here
for no good reason.
And so one of the
things I want to make
sure to mention during this talk
is that sometimes this approach
is absolutely OK.
I mean, there are
going to be times
when we do have incredibly
sensitive information
that we're working with.
And it's going to be
information that absolutely
does have to be locked down.
It's not something
we can take lightly,
that we can allow just
anybody to get access to.
And so I don't want you walking
away from this talk thinking,
this guy doesn't
understand our security.
We're in the financial
industry, and we've
got people's bank accounts,
so we need to do this.
Absolutely.
One of the key takeaways
here is that it's really
a matter of looking at the
APIs, understanding the threats,
understanding how we can get
the API out as much as possible,
and recognizing that sometimes
we don't want it out at all.
So in this case they
had to figure out,
who's actually authorized
to access patient data.
So in this case, it was
very clear that they had--
depending on the patient's you
were assigned as a physician,
they wanted to make
sure you would only
see the information
for your patients.
And so as a result, we had to
have a way for these doctors,
and nurses, and other
caregivers to authenticate.
And so traditionally, one of
the problems we've faced--
and especially in
the web space--
is direct user authentication.
And we've seen, over
the years, we've
done single
sign-on-type solutions
and things like that, whole
products have sprung up
to solve the SSO problem.
And so from an API
perspective, we
have a similar construct with
a delegated identity and user
authorization.
So a lot of times,
this will be things
like OpenID Connect where we
can allow users to sign in
without ever exposing
our passwords
and our credentials
to that application.
We can use OpenID Connect
and obtain an OAuth token.
So this is often what we would
call a three-legged OAuth where
somebody will sign in.
If you've seen things like
sign in with Google or sign
in with Facebook, a
lot of organizations
are building their own
sign in with our platform
and then using those in
conjunction with API management
to send an OpenID Connect
request, get back the response,
and then exchange that
for an access token.
And now, what we can do
is we can identify the end
user that's making
these API calls,
and we can do fine-grained
access control
checks to make sure
that only the physicians
and other caregivers
that should have access
to this particular patient's
information have access.
One of the other things
that they had to think about
was auditing.
And so they wanted to be
able to keep track of who
looked at a patient's data.
So again, when
we're looking at--
not just from the
standpoint of people
trying to hack
into this account--
but just from an auditing
and compliance requirements
standpoint, a lot of times they
would have specific samplings
that they would have to do.
So they had to go
back and prove--
you've built this API, and over
the course of the last year--
let's pick a specific patient,
anonymized, of course,
and let's look at who
actually made a request in
to get this particular
patient's data.
And so what they had
to do is they had
to put in place audit logging.
And so we could go
back, and we could then
look and say, OK, great.
For this particular
patient, who has looked?
And let's make sure
that they have access
to have looked at that,
they were authorized
to look at that patient's data.
So even with all of
these capabilities
that we've talked about, we
can still end up with cases
where attackers find a way.
And so to talk
about that, I want
to invite up my
colleague Matt Blumberg,
to talk a little bit about
how we would address those.
MATT BLUMBERG: Thanks, Chris.
Good morning, everybody.
So my name is Matt Blumberg.
And I'm a product manager
focused on API security
at Apigee.
And as Chris talked
about, API abuse
is becoming much
more common and is
predicted to be the most common
attack vector in the enterprise
space in the next few years.
And I'm going to talk
about some of the features
that we offer to help you
protect your APIs from abuse.
So just with a raise of
hands, how many people
currently expose APIs
through a web app?
About 3/4?
And how many are exposing
APIs through a mobile app?
OK, about the same number.
So over the past
couple of years,
we've seen a significant growth
in public-facing APIs, which
is a very powerful
tool that will help
you transform your business.
But it definitely comes
with a responsibility
to protect those APIs.
And as much as the
security tools out there
today are great,
sometimes, abuse
can become much
more of a concern.
So in the enterprise
space, customers typically
take a multilayer approach.
And they typically deploy
a web application firewall.
And that does a relatively
good job for web,
protecting from the DDoS and
SQL injection, these types
of attacks, but
they fail to handle
the API-specific attacks which
is where Apigee Sense comes in.
So Sense leverages
API constructs
such as API keys
and access tokens
in the context of the workflow
to help identify behavior
which is past the WAF layer.
So when we analyze information
such as the user-agent and API
key and look at the
volume of that traffic
with other attributes
over a period of time,
we're able to detect API abuse
and bot traffic that WAFs
are not able to detect.
So I'm going to talk
for a minute about how
Apigee Sense works.
So we offer what we call
a closed-loop protection.
So this means that we're able to
analyze all of the API traffic
as it streams
across your proxies.
And we'll collect
this data and run it
through our analysis
engine which
detects anomalies and abuse.
And then our Sense
Console offers
insights about what type
of traffic it's observing
and allows you to review that
traffic and take action on it,
including blocking
it or flagging it.
And we'll talk about
that in a minute.
So I'm going to walk
you through what
a common attack may look like.
For many customers,
there's an expectation
of where they operate
their business, where
traffic should be coming from.
So maybe you're selling
products online.
Maybe you're a domestic airline.
But you typically know where
traffic should be coming from
or, definitely, where it
should not be coming from.
And at a glance
here, you can see
that the world map is covered
in higher-than-normal traffic
from all over the world.
So many countries,
there may be--
you're not allowed
to conduct business,
but you're seeing a
significant amount of traffic.
And in the top
corner, you can see
that the bot traffic has
increased by nearly 30%
in the near term.
So clearly, there is an
attack going on in this case.
So as we dive deeper to
investigate what's going on,
we can start by reviewing the
API abuse in the Detection
Report tool.
So this is where Sense analyzes
and lets you act on behaviors
that we can see that
exceed thresholds
that are set in the product.
So for example, there's
a Brute Guesser rule
which, in this case, was
violated more than 3,500 times,
3,500 different bots, resulting
in millions of malicious API
calls.
There's a full list of the
rules here that you can see
and the number of bots that
are exceeding those thresholds.
So this gives you an overview
of the different types
of protection that are offered
through the Sense product.
So in the previous
slide, I showed
an example of the Brute
Guesser policy being violated.
And you see higher
than normal traffic
that results in errors
over a period of time.
So that may be someone
trying to attempt to log in.
Or another example is
the Content Scraper rule
where a very common attack used
to scrape products and pricing
data.
So if you have mobile
apps for shopping or web
apps for the same
use case, those
may be scraped for pricing
product information
or, again, login-APIs and
these types of things.
So we have these various
thresholds and sets
of rules that offer protection
for those types of attacks.
So if we go back
to the attack, we
can see that all
of the API calls
were going after the
login-URI endpoint here.
So you can see that
the highest value
attacks, such as purchasing
payments, loyalty programs,
gift cards, and login are
the most commonly abused
and require the highest
level of protection
using tools such as Sense.
If we drill down on
a specific IP address
to investigate
further, we can also
see that most of the calls--
in this case, all of them--
were resulting in 401's
and 403's, meaning
unauthorized access.
So this is what triggered the
rule in this particular case.
So after review, I think
we have enough information
to make a decision to
block this traffic.
So Apigee Sense
offers you the ability
to allow, block, or
flag the API traffic.
So flagging would allow
you to add custom metadata
to the headers,
which may enable you
to configure a honeypot
or other system to deal
with the traffic.
You're also allowed to
block it, at this point,
to prevent that IP from
being able to continue
making API calls.
Or maybe you're running a flash
sale or some other scenario
where you explicitly want to
allow this type of traffic,
but that's in your control.
So as we can see here,
once we took action,
the malicious traffic stopped.
And we're constantly working on
adding new methods of detection
across our API products.
Google is making a very
large investment in security,
as you may have seen from
other sessions at Next.
And in Apigee,
it's no different.
We're making a very large
investment collaborating
across teams with the
broader Google security teams
to take the best security
features, machine learning,
and automation from
Google's products
and integrate that into the
future Apigee API products
in the security area as
well as other functionality.
[MUSIC PLAYING]